[Music]
louisa can you reroute the river will do
recent the donkeys got out again on it
lisa
wait a second
you got to tell me about the magic
what's going on what are you hiding
nothing just got a lot of chores so
maybe you should just go home lisa my
house is leaning to the top
dolores said your eye was twitching it
never twitches something's making you
nervous move you're gonna make me drop a
donkey
luisa we just
just tell me what it is there's nothing
to tell you're obviously worried about
something lisa if you know what's
hurting the magic and it gets worse
cause you won't tell me what's wrong
nothing's wrong
wow
sorry that uh that snuck out there
many years ago
this scandal blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
magic
la casita
[Music]
[Music]
i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with an adepa
con queso
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait how do i save the magic
[Music]
the fate of the family is gonna come
down to you i can't do this let me help
you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
[Music]
but at least i'll have a friend nope you
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
you